so as some of you awesome lovely people
may know I was not the biggest fan of
the newest die hard film as a huge
supporter of the franchise I was let
down by the seemingly careless sequel
and have some things to say and the
style of my Prometheus explained and
drive analyzed videos I present to you
everything that's wrong with die hard 5
before we get in depth here I'd like to
share with you something I discovered
while desperately trying to wash the
taste of 5 out of my mouth listening to
the commentary on die hard for Bruce
Willis said something very intriguing
that got my brain thinking here are
Willis's thoughts on a proposed early
draft of die hard 4 but there was a
draft an early draft that the studio had
showed me about my son and I going on
vacation or a kid in I and I it was my
idea actually that I said well if it's a
kid what if it was my son and a draft
were written like that but that story
became so top-heavy with the father son
who were estranged from each other that
it took away from the die-hard story
hmm a father-son story while on vacation
that became top-heavy and took away from
the die-hard story interesting glad that
didn't happen oh wait this just adds to
my suspicion that this entire movie was
essentially half-assed into theaters
from an old idea by a studio that just
didn't care now that we have that out of
the way let's get this list going now
I'll be the first to admit that despite
a rather convoluted plot rearing its
ugly head in the opening scene I was
still on board for the first 15 minutes
or so of this movie we see some
important looking people talking about
some overly complex plot can get a cool
scene where Jack McClane takes out a
baddie soon we are introduced to John
McClane and we get what in retrospect
feels like an obligatory scene to remind
us that he is in fact a police officer
by the way he acts and the rest of the
film you'd never know it though which
brings me to my first point John McClane
isn't John McClane
what are some of the things that you
love most about the character of John
McClane for me it was his ability to get
his teeth kicked in his face smash to
nothing and still smile about it it was
also that despite his rugged exterior he
truly cared about people and honestly
was just a good cop who wanted to help
in each previous film this is constantly
on display do you remember the scene in
die hard 2 after McClane failed to save
the crashing plane not only did he
nearly die trying but he sits there a
broken hurt man or how about in 3 upon
realizing the bomb isn't exactly where
he thought it was he stumbles to the
ground in tears in die hard 5 McClane
steals a random pedestrians car then
proceeds to crush a ton of civilian
vehicles including one with an innocent
woman actually inside it my point is
that in die hard 5 they lost all sense
of McClane as a person he doesn't care
about people anymore he's actually
become a little unlikable which is
unthinkable for one of the most likeable
protagonists in movie history now since
we're already talking a little about
that car chase which I might add was
edited by a team of monkeys I might as
well bring up another point reusing
lines from previous films and I
literally mean the exact same audio
[Music]
what is this see when I see things like
that I picture exactly what more than
likely happened you see they were in the
editing room and said we need MacLean to
say something witty here but we don't
have anything because we didn't write
anything and we didn't film anything
let's just pull it from the much better
previous film because we're too lazy to
actually do any work ourselves which
brings me to my next point in which I'm
just gonna group two things into one
because they feel like they're both
equally to blame the director and writer
the director is a man named John Moore
and taking a quick look at his
filmography leads me to believe the only
reason he was chosen for this job was
because his first name is John and his
last name starts with an M he has
directed behind enemy lines the remake
of flight of the Phoenix the remake of
the omen and the adaptation of the much
beloved videogame Max Payne which many
fans rightfully feel ruined their
beloved source material apparently the
people over at 20th Century Fox felt
that that combination of films added up
to the person they wanted to take
control of one of the most beloved
franchises in the entire world it's no
surprise that we got a film so shaky and
poorly edited people were wondering what
was going on half the time I mean did
Moore even watch the previous films all
four were directed smoothly and
efficiently with terrific editing and
mind-blowing sequences the best more
gives us is a bunch of cars flying in
all different directions and a crapload
of fake CGI BS I mean look at that was
like fucking shit fucking shit look at
it now the writer is a man named skip
woods and this is apparently a photo of
him there literally are like no photos
of this guy he may be an alien who came
to study our reactions to ruined
franchises he wrote swordfish hitman
Peck's pen origins Wolverine and the
18th I just don't know who sat down and
said that that writer and that director
had proven by their previous films that
they could take a hold of this franchise
because if it was left up to me a fan I
would say not a chance in hell number
four the villains
[Music]
each die hard film has a memorable
villain it's not just one of the most
important things for a regular action
movie it's an absolute must for a
die-hard film here the man you think is
the main antagonist will go down as the
guy who tap danced while eating a carrot
of course in some horrible twist which
makes the already jumbled and confusing
plot even more ludicrous the man the
McLean's have been protecting is the
actual villain and a character who is
already completely boring now becomes a
confusing boring person as a villain for
a normal action movie he's a fail as a
villain for a die hard movie he is a
complete disgrace there's nothing
interesting about him there is nothing
memorable about him he's just some guy
who wants some nuclear something or
other and no one cares it's just so so
poorly done this leads me to the plot I
honestly don't know what the hell is
going on in this movie if someone asked
me to explain the plot of die hard 5 I
really don't think I could nothing makes
sense in retrospect when you really
think about it and you get no sense of
realism when remembering the characters
and scenes it's just some thrown
together crapshoot of random events
there's no sense of depth in any of the
characters in the situation's they find
themselves in and most of the action
doesn't even feel tense which brings me
to my next point
there's no tension for me some of the
most memorable moments of the previous
four films involve McClane being
consistently
to within an inch of his life in each
previous film MacLean struggles to
survive through bullets fists knives and
even Jets there's a consistent level of
dramatic tension always underlying the
action as well with his family being in
danger or hostages or the city of New
York or something along these lines
there's always some great fight scenes
showcasing Maclean's ability to take a
hit and keep getting back up this
reminds us that our favorite movie
heroes are the vulnerable ones who can
get their ass handed to them yet persist
under pressure in die hard 5 MacLean
doesn't even have a fight scene there's
no fight scene and he's essentially an
invincible superhero throughout the
entire movie which means I don't relate
to him at all this movie was rated R
people were so excited that this film
was rated R but this proves anything
it's that a rating doesn't make the
movie any better
honestly except for a few bloody
headshots die hard 4 is more violent
than this movie and it's not even that
foul-mouthed either
according to kids in mind calm die hard
3 contains over 70 uses of the f-word
die hard 5 contains about 16 and I'd say
maybe five of them were actually from
the claim now I'm not one of the people
who debate about die hard for being
ruined by its pg-13 rating I think that
movies pretty badass on its own but to
the people who were hoping for a
hardcore r-rated die hard they still
didn't get it well guys I could probably
sit here all day doing this to coming up
with stuff left and right including why
in the world this was not in the movie I
mean it obviously happened so where was
it and why McClane and his son fall in a
pool infested with nuclear fallout and
are just fine but oh yeah he's a
superhero so it's all good
life moves on action movie fans thanks
for watching I appreciate it if you
would agree with anything I said leave
me a comment below and tell me what you
thought of die hard 5 I'll try to do
more analyze reviews as soon as I
possibly can and as always thanks for
watching and if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]